no fems mask only phrases you often see
on gay dating apps camp guys back of the
queue and my favorite straight acting
only when I see these I panic I recount
all of the times I've been told Wow I'd
never have known you a gay or I like gay
guys when they're like you like normal I
compare this to the number of times I
get told god you're gay or you're so
camp I love it how is it possible that
i've been told both so many times in my
life am i a bloke with a gay jekyll and
hyde street who sometimes transforms
into alan carr when Brittany comes on
the radio or am I a desperately camp guy
pressured into straight acting by our
heteronormative society for me many gay
guys are a bit of both the circumstance
at hand affecting how we express
ourselves do we deny our true selves
when we straight act I like to think no
do people behave the same way around
their parents as they do with their
friends or when they feel Piper or
confident embarrassed or subdued people
constantly present themselves
differently depending on the situation
and there isn't really anything
disingenuous or fake about it so am I
then or mask well a bit of both I guess
it depends and I'm certainly never
acting
you